[Music]
the southern nevada health district
opening up another vaccine location the
las vegas convention center will open
next week for those receiving their
second dose joe muller live there on
what you need to know
if you are waiting to schedule joe
oh brian the uh the las vegas convention
center here will start operating next
tuesday and if you need that second dose
you will be contacted by the health
district now this news comes
as some new pharmacies will now start
offering the vaccine here in southern
nevada
normally the convention center plays a
critical role in our economy
now it will help in the fight against
coven 19. we will be
offering the second dose of vaccine
at the convention center if you received
your first dose at cashman center the
health district office or
western high school starting tuesday
february 2nd you will be getting the
second dose at the convention center
the health district says they have
already started contacting people to set
up the appointments
with just that capacity it's around 40
50 000.
southern nevada is allocated around 22
to 23 thousand vaccine doses a week
during a weekly vaccine plan update
health district officials explain they
can easily administer more vaccines
than what is being administered now for
instance cashman's site
it's running just over a thousand now
it's only because of vaccine limitations
that would instantly be up to over 000 a
day while the county works to secure
more vaccines more neighborhood
pharmacies are starting to offer it
some of the pharmacies are receiving
vaccine and their target population
is 70 and up and walgreens and cvs have
started
appointments and more are to come
back out here live doses here will be
administered at
central hall dedicated parking is
available in a silver lot off of
paradise road and convention center now
if you believe
you should have been contacted by the
health district you are urged to contact
and we also have some more information
regarding appointments
up on our website that's
eightnewsnow.com reporting live here at
the las vegas convention center this
evening joe mullen 8 news now